there are some things the state cannot
do to direct the moral content of your
life and controlling your sexuality is
one of those things I'm Katherine manga
award for Reason TV and I'm here today
talking with Dale carpenter about his
new book flagrant conduct the story of
Lawrence v Texas thank you for talking
with us thank you I'm glad to be here
just as a kind of background give me a
quick summary of the case then why it
matters
the case was it's a decision of the
Supreme Court that struck down the Texas
homosexual conduct law which forbade
specified sexual activities between two
people of the same sex and in doing so
the Supreme Court said that this
violated the constitutional right to
Liberty which includes a right to adult
intimacy and privacy your book is about
the story behind the story in particular
that the case was presented and and
certainly before I read your book I had
this gauzy idea that it was kind of two
men in a committed relationship who were
you know just like the straight folks
except for unfairly targeted by the law
explain why that narrative was both
useful and false well it was useful
because that sort of narrative was a way
for the court to understand the case
such that it would be acceptable
constitutionally it would be like
protecting people who are in a committed
relationship and the court had come to
have a different understanding I think
of gay people over time because the
justices were more familiar with having
gay clerks and neighbors and friends it
was a false story I think because I
don't believe the police actually saw
anybody having sex and in fact I don't
believe the two men were having sex and
the gay rights attorneys quite
justifiably allowed the case to proceed
on the basis of the allegations of the
police set the scene for us a little bit
you know I think it's hard even in 2012
to really understand how much attitudes
toward homosexuality have evolved from
kind of the stage on which this case
takes place
well the sodomy laws in the United
States had gone back from the founding
and before the founding to the colonies
but they had always covered both
opposite-sex and same-sex activity and
were not just limited to gay people in
the 1970s some states like Texas began
narrowing their laws to focus solely on
on intimacy between two people of the
same sex and making only that criminal
but allowing others to have their own
right to privacy and sexual autonomy
that came out I think of an atmosphere
of real stigma attached to gay men and
lesbians all across the country but
especially in places like Texas and it
came out and the fact that the
legislature refused to repeal the law
even though it was asked to do so in
every session courts refused to strike
it down because people were not actually
getting arrested and the law was used to
brand gay men and lesbians as criminals
and therefore as a basis to deny them
jobs housing you name it across the
board you tell a great little story
about right as the oral arguments are
about to take place a sort of tip that
the the lawyer gets about Sandra Day
O'Connor can you retell that story for
us the attorney for Lambda Legal which
was the National gay rights group that
led the challenge against the Texas
sodomy law was about to get up and
deliver his oral argument to the
justices back in March 2003 and it's a
high pressure moment for anyone but
especially for this man in this case and
just before he gets up to deliver his
argument someone whispers into his ear
that justice O'Connor had just sent a
former clerk of hers and her lesbian
partner a baby shower gift since they
had had a baby that really encapsulate
the changes that occurred had occurred
on the court by the year 2003 when all
of the justices news
who was gay in contrast to 17 years
before when the court had upheld sodomy
laws in a case called Bowers versus
Hardwick and one of the justices told
his clerk that he had never met someone
who was gay even though that clerk turns
out to him himself had been a closeted
gay person so the case is just full of
ironies and
little twists throughout talk a little
bit about why this case is about more
than just gay right well in in part it's
about more than that because it revives
a constitutional doctrine that protects
a right to liberty and privacy and
sexual autonomy for adults it's a
limitation on the power of government to
intrude on our personal lives it says
some there are some things the state
cannot do to direct the moral content of
your life and control in your sexuality
is one of those things can you talk a
little bit about the kind of stagecraft
of these Supreme Court cases I mean what
what struck me was just how incredibly
powerful the the lawyers the attorneys
who kind of shaped the case shaped the
public's perception of the case how
powerful they are in rewriting the life
stories of these men I mean Lawrence had
a long term boyfriend who was not
involved in this case at all and this
person sort of erased from the story
among among other people you know is
your is your kind of sense that that's
very common and that much of what we
hear and see coming out of the court is
this narrowed kind of narrative or was
there something special about this case
well I think both of those things are
true actually it's it's common for the
court only to get a very distilled
essence of the facts which it then
reviews to determine things like
constitutionality the court is not does
not often get into the weeds of the
facts of a case and in this case the
court was not encouraged to do so in
part because there was no trial of the
police made a charge they arrested the
two men dragged him out of their home
took them off to jail find them and did
so on the basis what I believe were
false charges but the gay rights
attorneys had no interest in challenging
the factual allegations made by the
state so everyone's interest was in
seeing this version of the case proceed
through the courts the police not
wanting to admit that it wasn't true gay
rights attorneys wanting a challenge
involving the application of such a law
in a private space and our legal system
it turns out our criminal justice system
is not a search for truth it is not an
inquisitorial system we don't have a
Inquisitor who demands answers from
criminal defendants instead we have an
adversarial system and sometimes that
adversarial system works to ferret out
the truth and sometimes that edvard
adversarial system assumes a kind of
alternate truth that then becomes the
basis for a larger decision so the court
is essentially almost deciding a
hypothetical but but it doesn't matter
because this is the question that people
want the court to answer this is what
the court is for right I would say you
could certainly describe it as a
hypothetical although in this case
because the men were actually arrested
that arrest was not hypothetical and the
charges that were made against them were
not hypothetical and the problem that
the litigants had was that the police
weren't using this law to arrest people
in the privacy of their home and judges
were requiring that that happened before
you could challenge the law and yet and
yet the law was having an effect
throughout society so it was you in a
sense had to get around that technical
requirement of having to get arrested to
get at the meat of the law I don't think
the attorneys ever misrepresented
anything the police may have represented
something in the facts of the case and
the attorneys allow that to proceed and
took full advantage of it thank you very
much Dale carpenter thank you for reason
TV I'm Katherine Maggie ward